do you think that there's a link between
muslim immigration in europe and an
increase in sexual violence towards
european women
um
the answer to that is
yes and there are some caveats i've my
latest book is called pray
and the subtitle is islam immigration
and the erosion of the rights of women
the answer
my uneasy answer to this is yes the
caveat is not all muslim men
are misogynists and not all muslim men
harass or attack women or treat them
badly
but
there is a minority
and that minority is considerable
and that minority of
very young muslim men
have come from societies
where women are viewed differently from
the way they are viewed in europe and
once they come to europe they start to
behave in ways
that are hostile to women
sexual harassment graves gang rapes
even syndicates or grooming gangs that
prey on young girls
now what has islam goes to with any of
this
when you talk to
religious leaders muslim religious
leaders
what they say is
well the behavior of these men is wrong
but the fact that women are around in
public
uncovered
and by themselves is also wrong so then
they propose solutions that are
sharia-based in europe
that's one
number two
women are divided into those who good
and modest
and those who are bad
and bad women
whether it is
within
islam or within the tribal culture that
some of these young men come from
women who are regarded as bad are
regarded as unprotected
unprotected meaning unprotected by male
guardians
so in that sense what you see is
yeah and i have talked to some of these
young men
muslim men in europe and asked them why
is it that you can't if you behave this
way in egypt when you come to
germany why do you carry on behaving
this way
and
a lot of them who've actually
done some reflection on the differences
in societies just say
that they explain the differences and
they say
if i behaved this way in egypt or in
afghanistan or iraq i would meet with no
disapproval
the women who are targeted they are the
ones who are disapproved of because they
are the ones who put themselves in
trouble
and so
as you can see there's this big
clash of values or clash of civilization
i don't know what you want to call it
but on the treatment of women that
definitely is a clash of values when it
comes to the values of europe versus the
values of islam so on
the the the thesis and i'm not sure if
you want to ask this is a separate
question but the thesis that mcgann has
put forward
in her newest book pray is that actually
what you find is that muslim men the
immigration of muslim men to european
countries has increased rape this is
basically it and she mentions in page 33
of that book she says there's an actual
causal relationship
she says that there's a causal
relationship i've read her book the
entire book
and i've seen the data that she puts
forward for the claims that she makes
michaela and she and just go for the
idea
the idea is that muslim men immigration
coming into
european countries causes an increase in
rape that's what he's saying
now look
she mentions what is the data that she
mentioned she mentions data from about
five european countries including but
not limited to the united kingdom france
and sweden
now what she then states
is that there's evidence for a causal
relationship in page 33.
what is this data missing michaela this
data is missing
i mean this data has everything going
for it in fact except for the evidence
because this data does not even have
that these men are muslim men and that
might be a surprise and a shock to you
but this data is about where these men
come from so for instance she cites that
these men come from africa from uh
subcontinental asia but you will know
and i'm sure your viewers who are clever
people
who have been educated at a minor level
will know that africa is not it's not a
muslim continent the entire continent of
africa there are many muslims in it and
there are many christians in it so the
data is not conclusive in fact it
doesn't even show anything it just shows
that people coming from af there's an
increase of people coming from africa
and then there's an increase also in
rape okay well we tried the same
methodology michaela i actually tried
the same methodology with latin america
and america the united states of america
so people coming from latin america
which are not muslims as you know
when they go into america the united
states there is also a correlative
increase in rape now we can't say just
because there's a correlative increase
in rape and this is a fallacy by the way
that therefore the causation is those
people but even if we did say that
well latin americans are not muslim
latin americans are christians and
therefore the most part very small
muslim minor very very small and
negligible muslim minority and therefore
the whole thesis collapses
she even mentions and she lies through a
mission by mentioning data from the
world health organization and she is a
liar by the way she's a lie she lied to
the dutch parliament she lies by by a
mission by mentioning the who the only i
know the only data that has that the wh
has done on rape
and she she mentions certain things
about africa once again there's not even
a muslim continent in its entirety and
subcontinental asia but what she doesn't
mention is that according to the who
that same report that she mentions but
she omits this part
according to the who
that stranger rape is highest in what
they call the high income areas which is
the west so in other words stranger rape
is highest in
europe
or if you want to generalize europe and
america
and canada where you're from so wait a
minute what's going on here the whole
thesis starts to be destroyed and of
course as i've said to you before and
i'll say to you again islam prohibits
pre-marital
engagements between men and women how on
earth
can you get a thesis that says islam and
she mentions the word cause and it said
fallacy causes an increase in rape
for muslim men to non-muslim women where
islam limits it to the highest level
stranger rape funny enough according to
the who is lowest in areas which are
most populated by muslim people like the
subcontinental area
of course they say that's because the
cultural reasons of a woman coming out
and all that kind of thing that's their
analysis but that's not their data
furthermore
if it was to do with the jurisprudence
then we know that orthodox jews have a
very similar if not more strict way more
strict
kind of jurisprudential tradition when
it comes to the interaction of men and
women however
i will tell you michaela despite that
being the case we don't see
that that is causing any rape within
jewish communities or jewish men doing
that to non-jewish women
she mentions in her one of her
interviews that she does she says that
therefore muslim people need to be made
uh be taught how to be egalitarian we
believe in a complementarian system
where there's a managerial hierarchy and
the man's at the head of it we do
believe in that michael we're gonna lie
to you in the households that's we
really that's the only way we can do it
however
she's saying no she's trying to impose a
feminist narrative which you should be
opposed to and your father is already
opposed to which she says that she's
trying to uh that men that coming in
from abroad should now be kind of vetted
by told by being told what by being told
that they need to believe in the
egalitarian family system now if that's
the case that's not going to happen with
just muslims that should also happen
with christians with traditional
conservative values and it can happen
with jews as well and if that's the case
now she's ex this is a kind of corrosive
uh
restriction on on human freedom which is
unusual it's a creeping in of
collectivist discourse and it's very
unusual because in other places she
denies that she's a collectivist in
summary therefore i will say that the
thesis is most pathetic
and it's it's it is most
uh rejected it i it cannot be and it has
already been refuted by the way by many
many academics but for example jill
philippovich who's recently written a
comprehensive refutation of this
nonsense that this miserable specimen of
an academic charlatan has written
forward and some reason as being
is being taken seriously by people but
it cannot be taken seriously by people
this is basically let me show you
something and mikayla sensei on the
topic it's basically a rehashing
of
uh it's the rehashing of the jewish
discourses as you can see here the
fascistic juice the jewish problem you
see the white woman there and then the
jewish man can you see this kind of
thing can you see it i'm not sure if you
can see that this is the kind of thing
before uh i'm not sure if you can see
that or not
a little bit closer would probably be
better can you put that a bit closer
please
this is the kind of newspaper article
where the jewish problem the white woman
there's the prize and all the people the
jewish man there bring it back a bit
bring it back
bring it yeah yeah yeah can you see it
wait a
this is before what happened the pogroms
and whatever happened this is the
discourse she's just it's just rehashing
a fascistic discourse and
being academics and clever people we
should you know i'm sure people in the
new conservative movement or the
alt-right whoever is in america and in
the west will be able to see this what
it is it's nonsense it's academically
redundant and it is the most ridiculous
thesis i've ever seen in my life by
someone who has no peer-reviewed work
and should not be taken seriously by
anybody